Speaker 1: Alex Jones is now begging for money
from his audience for the lawsuit that he lost
on the Wednesday bonus show. I told you that
in a case where the plaintiffs are Sandy Hook
parents of victims from the Sandy Hook shooting
in 2012, the plaintiffs are suing Alex Jones for
defamation. The court has found against Jones, but
not on the merits yet on the basis that Jones is
obstructing discovery. That's the finding so far,
so he's trying to prevent this from even getting
to the next level where he may actually be
found liable for damages for defamation itself.
Alex Jones is now saying he needs money. He needs
$2 million. In order to pay for all of this,
take a look at what he had to say.
Speaker 2: Trials, even though I've
already been found guilty by default, now they're
going to try to tell the jury how guilty I am
Speaker 1: now, even that's deceptive.
I've been found guilty by default.
You obstructed discovery. You're supposed to
allow discovery and you did, and it's not guilty
by default. You're not allowing discovery.
Speaker 2: It's going to take a lot of money
to fight this and a lot of money for the appeals.
And so I can't spend the money we have paying our
crew and running our independent media outlets.
Millions of people without your support, Infowars
is doing its most important work ever right now,
Speaker 1: so I would argue that that's not true.
Speaker 2: This is a no brainer. Please
go to shave Infowars.com make a $10
donation. A thousand dollar donation. Wealthy
people out there. Your free speech is being
destroyed. Infowars is just the first,
Speaker 1: you know, most wealthy people,
most people, but certainly most wealthy
people know their free speech is not being
destroyed. Their free speech is fine to fall.
Speaker 2: And if wealthy folks don't start
spending their money promoting liberty, promoting
freedom, we're going to lose this country
and we're going to lose the world. So please go
to save Infowars Dotcom. It's Gibson, go. They're
great, folks. They're patriots. We're banned
everywhere else. You've been able to raise money
and this will help keep us the fight for the
next few years. So I've never issued an alert
to serious I need your help right now.
Speaker 1: That's also not
true. There's always some alert.
Speaker 2: Stand up for yourself. Stand up for
your right. Stand up for free speech. Stand up for
America. And don't let these bullies intimidate
anybody. Please donate right now. Save him.
Speaker 1: OK, now that is what desperation
looks like, but I hate to tell you guys he's
raising a bunch of money. This campaign started
a day and a half ago. The goal is $2 million.
He's already raised just a few dollars short
of $100000 by the time that this clip gets
published and today's podcast gets published.
It may be a lot more money, so this is
what desperation looks and sounds like.
I guess the risk is we may lose Infowars
altogether if we don't donate to Alex Jones,
which doesn't seem like it would really be that
bad of a thing. Quite frankly, it seems like
actually that that might be something that has
positive influence. So Alex Jones, as I told you,
not yet actually found liable on the merits of
the defamation case, but they are declining to
actually do what they're supposed to do when
it comes to discovery to even allow this to
go forward despite a judge's requests slash
demands, depending on what you want to call them.
And now Alex Jones is turning it into the grift
of gifts. He made money by making by lying about
Sandy Hook. He then got sued, and now he's trying
to make money by painting himself as the victim
as a result of not participating in
what the court said. He has to do
discovery for this case. I don't think anybody
in my audience is going to donate, but people are
donating. He's already up to almost $100000 and
probably more by the time we published this club.
It's an amazing time that we live in. I want to
remind everybody again. We will be off next week,
Thursday and Friday for the Thanksgiving holiday,
just so people don't email. And you say, David,
where's the show? Where's the show? We're going
to be off Thursday and Friday. We will be here
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday. We're going to take
a quick break. I want to hear from some of you.
I have questions to answer. I have emails to
address and show you. You can also, of course,
find me on Twitter at David Pakman. Look forward
to hearing from you. Please make sure that you
are signed up at join Packman dot com, grab
a David Pakman show membership. Our program
primarily depends on people signing up for those
memberships, and we do an extra show every day
called the bonus show for our members. We
also have commercial free audio and video
streams of the show. Sign up at join Packman
dot com! Great way to support independent media.